what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for another pretty problems
interview I have the pleasure of
welcoming kestron and Vanessa back to
the channel after celebrating the
premiere at South by Southwest and JJ
and Britt welcome to the collider
interview YouTube channel for the very
first time hello thank you
congratulations on your movie I had only
seen it once last time and I enjoyed it
very much but now I can confirm it is
even more enjoyable on a second watch so
seriously congratulations thank you we
got a repeat all right I will I will
also say somehow this movie makes me
want to like run out and buy the biggest
bottle of wine I can get my hands on but
then also never drink it once I have it
we've done what we came here to do let
us know if you need us to help you drink
your wine I mean I uh I definitely can
call you in for some help with that
there's more than enough in this house
right now it has been a long fall and
fall has only just begun
all right let us get into it uh Brit I
will come your way first because if I
have my details right here you came up
with the idea for the movie with Michael
and Charlotte so what sparked the idea
to begin with and also what made the
three of you think like yes this idea
that we have here is worth fleshing out
a free feature screenplay well I think
it really isn't more complicated than
the the old adage for
um Indie filmmaking which is use what
you have and so the idea came about
because we were able to get our hands on
the property and that was a friend of
the family lending one of their
properties when they go to one of their
other properties while they're in Europe
at another property
anyway they were very happy to let a
bunch of Scrappy filmmakers come in and
use their home and so that is where it
was born and much like you know if you
knew you had a restaurant at your
disposal you better write a restaurant
story because that's what you've got and
your budget's gonna be small
um so that's where we started it was
really the inspiration and we thought
wow what would it be like to be invited
into this place and think all at once I
wish I had it but also do I belong here
what have I done with my life what is
happening and we kind of toyed with the
idea of it being a little tense and a
little bit of a thriller
um which we pulled back from in a lot of
ways as we leaned more into the comedy
as we started to develop the story
um the laughter became one of the most
important parts so um that that was the
beginning and and now you've seen where
we went with it I have many follow-ups
but the biggest one of the bunch is are
you still friends with this homeowner
will they let you share another movie in
their house honestly
filmmaking capital on that specific
property
but uh yeah let's shoot the next ladies
night there how about that that's yeah
we're doing the next one it's amazing
but I'll put all the bottles in my
suitcase and I will be there in a
heartbeat that's all we need I will say
every Festival we've been to since uh
anyone that I make friends with I have
started to ask do you can we use your
property do you um you have um this
amazing truck and it's giving me a story
it really is people are very generous
and they're very eager to help
filmmakers
um if you if you catch them at the right
moment when they're feeling inspired so
we were very very fortunate that's all
this new watch out Mary
look out she's going to come for your
cat colony next yes
they they are open and welcome to
filming they would love to have their
story told especially in like Pixar
format I think that's what they're
gunning for at the moment but uh there's
a great shooting location in this
backyard right now great I love it I
work I will work up a pitch let's go
going back to what you were saying about
uh it going from more of a thriller to a
comedy when did you all discover that
happening is that something that was
happening while you were fleshing out
the script or while you were actually
working with the material on set I think
it actually happened with it like we
were reading it in the table reads and
it was confusing and I remember being
confused around the first read and was
like I don't totally understand this
right now and then when we did table
reads it wasn't it wasn't gelling and I
think everyone kind of sensed it in
their solar plexus when you're like Ugh
what's happening
experience of it yeah we kept getting
feedback like oh well if it's a Horror
Story what about and we're like oh no no
no no we gotta pull back because if it's
if people are picking this up on the
page then we've got to modify a few
things there was like a crazy dream
sequence that got cut that was the most
misleading part
um but it was really fun it was fun to
write But ultimately if it's not serving
the story
gotta go
I mean I'm very happy with where you
landed on the movie but when you just
bring up the horror genre I'm like go
down that path yeah shooting location
I'll bring the wine I'll bring some cats
too and you make a horror movie yeah
yeah I love it harmed no cats can be
harmed but oh no that's the rule always
we can harm the actors it's fine
what's not dying in any movies on my
watch
um no but my my friend was like
um you know it like the horror element
like obviously like doesn't you know the
horror element didn't pay off but like
these people are more horrifying than
any horror movie
marriage
um JJ and Vanessa for you going through
that process during the table read what
is the biggest difference between how
you looked at your characters when it
felt more like a thriller compared to
who they turned out to be in the final
film oh I for sure I I was I mean
when I first the first time I don't know
about the table read but the first time
I read the script I was like oh there's
going to be a lot of murder happening
and I hope that my character is the one
to do it and I feel like if the if if it
did go further in that direction that's
it probably would have ended up being
what what happened with the story but um
yeah no I uh
I
um
I was actually playing a different
character when we did the table read so
my perception is totally different who
were you playing I must know
I was playing the role that Charlotte uh
ended up playing Carrie one of the
carries oh my God can I ask how that
changed and what inspired that shift uh
the inspiration for the shift was
um Charlotte Charlotte uh wanted to to
switch roles and yeah I'm actually gonna
I'm gonna blow up JJ a little bit
because JJ came in and auditioned for
Carrie uh because you know Charlotte was
was like I'm gonna play a cat this is
gonna be fun and then JJ came in and did
such an amazing job it was so hysterical
it was unbelievable and we got out of
the casting session and Charlotte was
like yeah I think I might want to play
that part I thought she had such an
acting crush on JJ and so you know
kesterin
um intervened and and talked to JJ
because she had brought JJ in to
audition in the first place
um and luckily everybody was really
happy to switch and now I I truly
couldn't imagine it any other way I
think everybody landed right where they
needed to be
yeah yeah it was pretty cool I mean I
will never forget Michael calling me and
be like hey uh what's the idea
um would you be interested in uh
switching roles with Charlotte and I was
like wait what yeah absolutely I'm yeah
I can't imagine it any other way but but
Carrie was a really fun role so uh yeah
it was just a lot more work
which I was down to take on for me it
was different because I actually I'm so
grateful that I was even included in
this but I was probably roped into the
project like a year after they had
started so I was not part of the table
read and I've known question and JJ for
at least a decade and Castro just hit me
up and was like Hey we're trying to work
out this one scene on Zoom would you
mind just like playing around with us
for a little bit and I was like oh girl
all day I did not know I was even in the
running or considered for the role I
thought it was just like collaborators
let's figure it out and question's like
okay cool Vanessa can you read and I'm
like what like I don't know if I told
you this Brit I was not prepared I
completely
I completely improved in the zoom and
was like well you can't act like you
didn't know what you were doing you just
gotta do it and then two days later
um castron hit me up and was like the
producers want to book you and I was
like wait what that worked and I knew JJ
was in it and I will literally follow JJ
to the ends of the Earth so I was like
I'm doing it and so it was just like oh
I get to play around with a bunch of my
friends and I read the script on the way
to Sonoma and I was like holy bleep I
didn't realize this was so funny I was
already in and this is amazing
so I love talking about uh people who
find each other and kind of know that
they see good collaborators in each
other so given the fact that the three
of you have been friends for a good
while did you always know that in
addition to being friends you were gonna
be good collaborators and creators
together or did something like that pop
up later on in your friendship later on
I but I kind of like Catherine inspired
me
um at a certain point like a few years
ago
um way before the pandemic but or I
don't know that feels like 20 years ago
but um
I was like I I hit up question one day
and I was just like can I just like get
in your orbit a little bit because like
she's always like learning Mandarin
while like raising two kids and like
Writing Movies and like doing all this
stuff and I'm just like I don't learn
um but yeah I I got inspired by her at a
certain point and she kind of like let
me come into her um orbit a little bit
and uh and and and then yeah I guess
after that like after working on the
karaoke RV together
mine was really simple I met question at
a pool party and she took a photo of JJ
and I and I was like this is the best
photo I have ever seen you take every
photo of me and I didn't realize she was
a director so then when she was like I
direct I was like wait you allow your
eye to capture me moving whatever you
want I'm in
all right I'm gonna add to that and go
back to something that kestron told me
the last time we spoke because I need to
hear from you now she referred to as a
witch and said that you sent her a cold
email asking her to direct this script
so what was it that inspired you to like
essentially no I I guess like not really
take a chance because you had already
seen her her last film but I guess you
are in a sense taking a chance on her as
a collaborator because you don't
necessarily know what it's like working
with her yeah yeah I I knew that we were
looking for someone that had style that
was my number one desire uh because the
script was finished we we knew most of
the the cast we had a really strong
community and a really strong vocabulary
between all of us but we needed somebody
at the helm that could really hold a
vision and that was something that I
knew that Michael and I could not handle
we could not handle holding that while
also being in front of the camera and so
we wanted someone that was just going to
like blow our minds and uh another woman
who I worked at the studio with uh
suggested she's like oh you know you
might like Kester and Pantera of what
you want to style and so I looked her up
on her website and was like oh my gosh I
loved her trailer I loved Mother's
Little Helpers
um so yeah I pitched her hard in an
email and and got the first date and
what was extra wild was that we went and
had the coffee date
um luckily she loved the scripts we made
it to a second location it was magical
and then of course naturally we're like
okay I think this is gonna work so I
followed her on Instagram and there was
this photo of her at Sundance in this
crazy like fur hat absolute like
standout knockout photo
so I was at Sundance that year I was by
myself I was flying out and I witnessed
this woman in front of me having a total
meltdown and this other woman like very
gently guide her through the process of
just like getting out of the airport
getting into a lift and I she just
Managed IT so beautifully and I was
thinking to myself holy [ __ ] like that's
great leadership right like I was like
that was a really interesting thing to
witness that was so like very intense
um it was kestron she was wearing the
Hat I remembered that she was the woman
in the Hat and so I knew right away that
I had already watched her at an
incredible leadership position managing
you know a difficult situation with
style and with presence and I was like
that's it man like I already stalked you
on accident like this is this is
absolutely our director so luckily she
felt the same way
you are an airport Saint keep making
movies but I feel like if you just hang
around airports and calm people down
this world would be a better place yeah
it's true
it needs some calming in that
environment so we will welcome you with
it also it's a stylish for hats oh my
God but she did it with this gorgeous
hat on
here right now it's appropriate bring
the Hat yeah formerly known as the woman
in the Hat which is amazing I love it
all right a random question that was
sparked by uh something another director
had told me recently she brought up a
quote that she heard from Joe Wright and
it's something like you should direct
movies that you feel like you know a
secret about or you should pick scripts
to direct that you think you know a
secret about and it could be interpreted
a whole bunch of different ways but what
was your pretty problems secret what was
something personal to you that you
thought you could bring out of it that
nobody else could first off I love Joe
Wright and I love that quote
um
Pride and Prejudice is one of my
favorite movies
um okay so what my secret was in this
movie is that I grew up in a really
small poor town
um that's like the middle of nowhere
that had like the highest teen pregnancy
rate in crystal meth like in the state
of California
and then at a certain point I went to
this crazy crazy school for high school
that was like in a castle on a hill it
was like Harry Potter going to Hogwarts
where you're like what is going on and I
ping-ponged between these places of like
insane
um disparity and you kind of learn how
to chameleon into different situations
and also you're not like when you're
that young when you're like 13 years old
maybe you're not quite as threatened by
it because you don't realize what's
going on you just kind of grock in and
you rock into both situations and so
like later on in life in like my 20s I
was like oh that was a really uniquely
weird experience but it
has helped me like in the in the
chameleon Department the other part was
um in
throwing crazy ass karaoke parties and
like my like secret burning not secret
like I go to burning man like I love
going to crazy like insane parties and
throwing them even though like my like
experimenting with substances career
like ended like before my college year
ended so I'm like pretty sober but I
still like hanging out and like being
around it and so making a movie where
people are doing all these crazy romps
is kind of my favorite place to live
because it's not actually happening but
you get to like experience it and
recreate it now because I'm curious is
there any kind of like crazy event type
thing left on your bucket list whether
it's something that you want to throw
yourself or something that already
exists out there that you want to go to
um yes I want to do a hot air balloon
Sunrise rave and I would also like to do
it in or near Morocco
like a group of hot air balloons raving
in the sky can I join yes can we ask
diploma
okay oh that sounds incredible I have so
many questions I'm like I'm like I'm
scared but I also want to go so I'm not
really sure how to navigate this I kind
of like can I have a blimp with a couple
of friends so I can feel like it's the
Cure I think maybe you could hold down
the forward on land side
Fuller experience to have both levels
covered
um Vanessa for you I wanted to follow up
on something that you brought up during
our last chat and uh JJ and you can feel
free to add to this as well if you want
but you had said that kestron's mind
works and kestron's mind works in like a
real unique way and how she executes
what her mind sees in a really unique
way and I was hoping you could kind of
like elaborate on that a little bit what
makes her eye different than other
directors you've worked with and what
makes her approach to executing that
Vision different as well okay first of
all I'm so impressed by myself for
saying that in the past wow okay thank
you for reminding me
um you know I think the thing thank you
for reminding me of my of me
appreciating kestron's genius because
it's something that I've noticed I've
been doing a lot of lately
um just in general I'm a huge
cheerleader and fan of all my friends
like the major I don't even try on
purpose but somehow I look around and
I'm surrounded by some of the most
talented and grounded and incredible
people that I've ever met and that's in
different spectrums they all have
something super special about them and
the thing that kills me about kestron is
and in the best way that keeps me alive
it kills me and keeps me alive is that
the way that your mind takes in
information and then processes it into a
creative perspective to show us the way
that you
acclimate any of the creativity or
inspiration that you guys it just blows
my mind and it's so unique to you and I
feel like
I've worked with a lot of incredible
directors at different stages of my
career and their own career and the one
thing that I've always loved and one
thing that you do that reminds me of
someone that Perry's a fan of Mr Steven
Spielberg is he's got a very specific
vision and I feel like that's what I see
anytime I hear a text or phone
notification from castrin I'm like holy
[ __ ] I'm about to be let into an
incredible vision and maybe she wants me
to be a part of it and the thing that's
so wonderful is you can tell how much
she understands the story she's trying
to tell because
once everyone on set
gives what she needs and we all are so
prepared she's like got it move on
and
you don't get that a lot you don't get
someone who has a vision it sees it
acknowledges it and more importantly
just also Praises us for helping her do
her job so there's a lot of aspects to
the diamond that is question that I
enjoy being a part of
you follow me with me for your next
movie no big deal
how did I do
salt
yeah but I just everyone it's really
been awesome I've been doing a lot of
projects where there's been more of a
female presence on set and there's
something that
is so different and comforting and
especially with this movie I was just
like holy [ __ ] like director producer
writer the majority of the cast like a
cam B cam deep yeah like I just was like
this is powerful and I love being here I
don't even feel like I'm doing work I
love it all
um JJ brittu either of you want to add
something before I move on to my next
burning question yeah yeah I think one
of the things that customer brings to
the table that's pretty prolific are her
editing skills she is an incredible
editor not just like an editor like an
amazing editor and so the way she can
multitask when she's directing she can
be so clear about no I won't need that
or yes I will need that that will cut
together and then she also has B cam
running around getting like b-roll
footage that she knows she's gonna need
to fill in other moments and her ability
to be efficient with time without
sacrificing any of the vision is really
incredible and I I do think you know
they say you're not you say you're not
really a multitasker in the world or
like your brain can't really multitask
but I just think that's [ __ ] because
I watched it happen right in front of my
eyes it was like spinning plates but
there was there was not there was never
an energy of pressure and we stayed on
schedule it's actually talking about
this with someone last night we had two
days that we went over by like two
minutes maybe three minutes that was it
we were completely on schedule we got
everything we needed we even got a
reshoot in there because she built in
two days for reshoots because once we
were out of this property that's it
there was no going back there was no
like building the set in a studio it was
and it was done so effortlessly that it
seemed effortless I mean there of course
moments of panic and high stakes but it
felt like there was such a presence to
be able to move through and multitask so
we had everything we needed it was I was
so comfortable with her in a position of
leadership because I think she has such
a wide range of skills yeah and just
from a performer's standpoint
um the the the trust that she has in her
actors is
um
it it it it's it's it's great because we
she would give us permission to uh like
we would have to get like you know take
um we'd have to get a take first like to
the scripts and then she would be like
she would just let us kind of
have fun
riff
um so as soon as we got it we would just
start riffing which is like really fun
and it just implies a lot of trust with
the performers and I love doing that I
want to follow up on what you just said
Brit so you go you go through the whole
shoot you're totally on schedule movie
making Miracle right there what is an
example of one of those days where you
know things weren't going to plan and I
don't know maybe you found a creative
solution to Pivot
um yeah well we the campfire scene was
you know already a challenge if you're
outside there's smoke blowing in our
faces we had just sat down and Rewritten
a bunch of things we'd Rewritten that
scene several times uh JJ and I had
cracked at it Michael and I had cracked
at it then all of us sat down at the
table and were working on it it still
wasn't working just the way that we
wanted it to and so we were we were
riffing we were trying customer was
asking things and we and it's night time
it was a night shoot so we were about to
run out of time because we promised our
crew that we would not screw them over
on time it was a promise that we made
everyone came on this property we were
all Indie filmmaking like sacrifices
were made and the one thing we were not
going to do was push them into overtime
um and we there was a lot of Integrity
around that and it was like we just
needed me walking up the hill we had to
get me walking up the hill because if I
didn't walk away we didn't have the
scene and Catherine was just like it's
Ali's call and Ally just like you know
she asked only one of her people to stay
with her and we got it in about two
minutes and it was just that quick shot
walking up but it was so respectful and
there was no pressure Ali could have
said no and we would have found another
way but we didn't have to because there
was so much respect throughout that it
was in one of those moments that
everyone wanted to say yes and do what
we needed to do to get it done and I
think that's you know that builds up
over time that kind of relationship I
love that so much I feel like building
on our last conversation like your onset
environment is exactly what every single
set out there should try to emulate
because things like that don't happen
very often and that is unfortunate I was
going to say to build on to your point
and then Perry you also said it I feel
like we've all had the pleasure of being
on different sets whether or not it
built us up or broke us down and
something that was so special about this
set was just a bunch of really grounded
incredibly compassionate human beings
that were like Hey we're all just like
having fun together in an adult way but
we can also be respectful and I feel
like I was only there for a couple of
days and there was just so much mutual
respect every single person was there to
support each other and I feel like
that's a testament to why this film is
so awesome is because everyone was there
to support each other there was no
hierarchy there was no inability to you
know speak up if you felt uncomfortable
and I feel like as a performer you have
to feel grounded and safe in a space to
do that and it starts with the director
and it was just a massive trickle-down
effect and you could feel it with every
single person
oh
come across the whole time
too no
um
we cannot stand you
right away
uh JJ burning questions for you I don't
know how much you actually thought about
this with your character but I started
to uh to think about it have you ever
considered if like if not money and if
not having all the things that you
needed what could have made cat happy in
life
I don't I don't think that
I mean okay let me like seriously
consider because my initial response is
like nothing obviously
um
um
but maybe what could have made cat happy
um
well I mean if she had dug a little
deeper I think
um earlier on in life not necessarily
early on but if she ever gave herself a
shot at
um
giving herself the freedom to like just
just like because she she put all of her
happiness in her husband and his success
um so she never really got a chance to
know herself
um so I think there's something very
very there's like that could maybe be
the beginning of starting to fill that
deep deep
morbidly
or dark hole in her heart but
um
yeah I think it would be a
soul-searching I guess which is maybe
the same for anyone but um
yeah I love that JJ because you you came
to the table and I remember you asking
at one point you're like I'm trying to
figure out like what like when did cat
meet Matt
um it was meant to be funny in the name
time uh but like when did cat meet that
and what was she doing before then like
what did she go to school for what did
she love what what what would she have
done if she didn't decide to say yes to
this and I thought that that was I I
mean we didn't get your answer because I
think it was very internal but I love
that you were asking those questions
because it was important to what you
brought the texture of the character was
there like I didn't know what it was
that she missed but she missed something
she took her she took a right when she
could have taken a left
um and I think that's a really
interesting question
yeah yeah yeah I yeah I don't know if I
should share the back story but yeah no
I think that she she had something going
on for herself and she let it go
she let go of the things that drove her
or like you know and and that's why
she's always on this like constant like
this endless
cyclical search for something to bring
her some Joy so she but she puts all of
her stock and other people making it
happen so like she invests in new
companies and stuff because
there I think there was something
earlier on before she gave she let go of
it so there was that part of her that I
was thinking about another dog
I feel I feel like puppies and kittens
make make everything better so right
you're obviously a cat person
first then I became a cat person and now
now I'm a both person I was thinking I
was thinking about you kestron last
night because I was doing a q a with a
with an acting coach and she had
mentioned one of her techniques that uh
has come in handy is you know having
having an actor play with an animal with
a pet on set and I was remembering you
uh you had your cat on this set but it
really did make a difference I think
yeah it's like a very anchoring
experience it brings people it brings
out the best in people all right to wind
down here this is like a very dangerous
thing for me to do virtually but because
you brought up the horror spin on the
movie and the Thriller spin earlier I
kind of want to play a game with you all
so this is a game that I go to
frequently because I love horror and I
love slasher movies in particular so
okay we are going to turn the set of
pretty problems into a slasher movie and
the only way one way I can do this is
I'm going to give you a superlative and
you need to tell me which real person on
set best suits this description but it's
whoever shouts out an answer first is
going to be the right answer to this so
good luck to whoever has the slowest
internet connection the first one is
who is the most likely to not realize
that there's a slasher on set and go and
investigate a strange noise and be the
first one to get killed off JJ
I didn't know I was like JJ's gonna be
like I hear a sound and you're gonna
just start moving already
yeah I mean probably I would argue that
pestering is going to be the first one
to investigate a noise
but I don't think that she would die I
feel like kestron would invest in making
noise from like where we all are and
just be like it's over there
you're the Curious one you're gonna go
look yeah did anybody hear that no it's
not interrupting her shoot okay [ __ ] it
let's go that would be custard unless
they could get someone else to go do it
I would like yeah
but like in life Castro's gonna be the
first one to actually go figure out what
the noise is she's gonna oh
oh yeah it's katja's gonna die we
actually did we actually did we did have
a hummingbird get stuck in the house
like inside like this this glass like
solar entry way and she was the one who
was like I think something's wrong and
she went and found the bird and then
Graham and Alex went and like got on a
ladder and saved it and their little
hands so I'm sorry in your horror movie
everyone would die
Victor
all right here's my next one for you
let's go with who is the most likely to
trip and fall while running from the
killer Charlotte I Melissa I know you
want to see me
issues
to
answer
I was like I'll just look away
did you say you were Barefoot you were
Barefoot I think Charlotte was in those
crazy heels all the time no no it's
definitely Charlotte I just think it's
funny how much we want it to be JJ but
it's Charlotte yeah
he's killing people let's go this is one
of my favorite ones of the bunch who is
who's the most likely to basically just
give up right from the start to say like
[ __ ] this it's too scary I'm leaving and
just walk off and then get killed by the
slasher oh
I think Graham I think Graham Bridge
Graham yeah yeah
Graham's like I'm going to law school I
have to go
yeah
yeah
that's probably Graham I'll give you two
more here who is the most likely to be
the last one standing I was gonna say me
because I'm just lucky like
lucky I don't know if that really has
anything to do with this situation
so maybe I'll make it
I think I could make it
I think Alex Klein would have like gone
to another room to read a comic book or
something and like miss the whole thing
and he would obliviously survive because
he had no idea people were dying yeah
he'd be taking a nap in the safest room
that nobody knew yeah yeah and then he'd
wake up and be like what happened
where did everybody go slept through the
murders that's like a good new
description that I should throw into
this list I have a feeling he'll be the
answer to this last question then who is
the most likely to be the one that you
think is dead but is actually alive and
comes back at the last possible second
to save the day
JJ she went to go check the sound we
thought she died but then she came back
JJ went to go down
and then she didn't die and I was crying
I think that works I believe it all I
also have to say it's a various it's a
special occasion right now because this
is officially Malcolm's First full
interview he's popped in to like one or
two he is not set in a single interview
yet from top to bottom until this one
and I'm pretty sure it's because he
senses the Good Vibes but also Vanessa
because you are here and he is named
after your dad I love that we're family
seriously
all right I am going to let everybody
out there know that pretty problems
premieres in theaters and On Demand on
October 7th so it will be available when
you're watching this interview
congratulations to all four of you now
go back to the house make another movie
and I promise to show up with wine and
cats yes please
thank you Perry hi or be the hero